YAIR WEINBERGER:
So I think by now
I don't need to convince
anyone that moving to the cloud
is useful and important.
And I think a challenge
at many, many enterprises
face today is how to do it.
And usually we have
this huge infrastructure
and servers and thousands
of different applications.
And in order to understand
how to move them,
we need to identify what
we want to move first, what
is going to be the most useful,
what is going to minimize
our disruption to our
current application, and most
importantly, how can we move
there as fast as possible.
So in general, we talk
about three different steps
in migration.
One is assessment,
understanding what
are the difficulties
that we are going to face
when we are going to migrate.
What is the expected downtime?
What should we
communicate to our users?
Then we do the actual migration.
After we finish migrating,
we tune our applications
to fit better to the cloud,
to fit better to the profile
that we are now running on GCP.
So usually what we--
in the first step
we even decide what
apps we need to move
and what apps can we even
move, because sometimes
not everything can be
just lifted and shifted,
and we are going to talk
about this in a minute.
But what dependencies
do we have?
Is everything going
to be shifted as is,
or are we going to
modernize something?
What is important
for application?
Do we have some specific
performance requirements
that might not be met
when we're in the cloud?
Do we have some specific
latency requirements?
And then, essentially,
that step will tell us what
is the right path to the cloud.
And we have--
I think in terms
of tooling, this
is probably the part that
is the most difficult today.
This is the part where there
is the least amount of tooling.
We are going to show
one partner that
has built an assessment
tool for migrating
a specific type of application.
But I think that,
in general, this
is the place where
we rely on knowledge,
and we rely on either the
engineers inside the company
or on our own PSO organization
to understand what the impact
is going to be for migration.
And in general, we have
different migration types,
and we need to
understand how exactly we
are going to migrate.
I think probably the
best way to migrate
is the first one, to
retire the application.
I mean, if we don't
need it anymore,
let's just shut it
down and that's it.
Migration is done.
Unfortunately, most
applications, we
don't follow this
pattern, and we actually
need to be more complex.
I guess if we can
also replace it
with some new
vendor or something
already in the cloud,
some SaaS vendor, that's
also pretty easy.
We first move to that
vendor and then retire.
But then when we
actually need to move it,
then we have a lot of options.
I guess the least
disruptive option, but also
usually the least useful,
is just to re-host it.
We take our servers as is
and we migrate those servers
into the cloud.
About six months ago
Google acquired Velostrata,
which is a company
that does VM migration,
and there are other Google
partners that do that as well.
Then we start getting
into the realm of actually
changing something
in the application
when moving to the cloud.
And again, this is usually
more disruptive, but also more
useful.
So we can revise
our application.
So maybe just move the VMs,
but also maybe containerize
some of them to be able to run
them on some container engine.
So just a little bit of change.
Or we can actually refactor,
so change the application
to different modules.
Some modules actually
move to new stuff.
Let's say we take
our database, which
we're going to talk about
in length in this talk,
and move it to
Cloud SQL, and then
we take the other part
of our application
and just move the VM as is.
And then we're going to the
things that usually are harder
to do, which is a complete
rebuild or complete rewrite
of the application
to fit the cloud.
I think where we are going
to focus in this talk is
on the refactor
area, where we want
to take some of our
footprint and move it
into cloud-native tools,
mostly to databases.
And then some of our footprint
we'll probably just keep as is,
and we'll just talk in
the same API the same way
but to new databases
that exist in the cloud.
And then once we're
done, of course,
we are going to optimize.
We're going to try
to optimize for cost,
going to optimize for speed,
going to optimize for latency.
That's only once
we're done moving.
And with GCP we
can actually-- we
have built and spent a
lot of time and effort
in order to build
migrations better.
And one is of
course fundamentally
making the cloud itself better,
making it scale, the network
performance, and the ability
to actually transfer data
at great speed, the service
level on the SLOs of GCP.
And then the migration
capabilities itself,
which are migration features,
migration tools, and migration
partners.
And eventually you're
not alone in this.
We have a very good
PSO organization
and support that will help
you throughout the process.
And as I mentioned, usually
during the assessment phase,
the pre-migration step is where
the organization is currently
most important compared to
the tooling that exists today,
but of course it's also very
useful in the migration itself,
and then in the tuning, because
those are people that actually
know what's best and
what best tool to use
and how to use
them in the cloud.
So let's talk about
different migration types.
One thing that actually works
very well today in Google Cloud
is we have the cloud compatible
of the on-premise stuff for--
Cloud SQL works both
for MySQL and Postgres.
We have Memorystore
for Redis which
is an API compatible to Redis.
And Bigtable and HBase
are also API compatible.
So if those are the dependencies
of your application,
refactoring should
be pretty easy,
as you will not need
to change any APIs,
you will not need to
change any drivers,
and your application
should just work
as is exactly the
same way it works
against the
on-premise databases.
So usually a very
common migration pass,
and the one that we are
going to extensively cover
in this session, is to move the
databases themselves to Cloud
SQL or Memorystore, and then
move the application using
probably VM migration.
And then you don't
need to change
anything in the application
itself or in the drivers.
And then, I would say maybe
the more interesting, but also
not as easy migration
path is when
we want to modernize database.
And this happens usually for
one of maybe two reasons.
One reason is we
need more scale.
We need better-- our MySQL
instance can no longer fit
the bill of what we need, or our
Postgres instance is no longer
scalable enough
for our data needs.
And that's why
we've built Spanner.
And Spanner is a low latency,
very high availability,
and scalable database
system in the cloud.
And it's not API
compatible in MySQL,
not API compatible
with Postgres,
but very, very similar.
So usually most of
the things that you're
able to do with MySQL and
Postgres, most of your queries
will just shift as is.
There will be some
work on understanding
what's not exactly compatible
and then moving that.
The other reason is I
have tools that are--
I would say I'm using
them for many years now
and I want to modernize them.
So I'm using Oracle, for
example, I'm using Cassandra,
and I want to move either to
Cloud SQL, to Cloud Bigtable.
Usually the main reason
we see moving Oracle
to Postgres in the cloud
is to reduce costs.
And then the Cassandra migration
that we see is just sometimes
at a certain size, it is
becoming very difficult
to manage your own
Cassandra cluster,
to understand the production
issues that are happening.
And then moving to
Bigtable usually
takes away a lot of this load.
We do have, for this--
again, the tooling here
are not as advanced, but we
do have a lot of guidelines,
a lot of experience, a lot
of migration guidelines that
will help you do this
and take you step
by step throughout
that process of doing
the heterogeneous
database migration.
So as some of you
may have heard,
Alooma acquired Google Cloud.
This actually has become
official last week.
Alooma has been focused
on data migration
from the beginning
five years ago,
and inside Google, myself
and the entire Alooma team
is going to be focused on
delivering a great database
migration experience,
and then expanding
the current capabilities
of the database migrations.
And the other side
is we don't think
that we can provide
everything ourselves,
and we don't think that you
can do everything yourselves.
And that's why we've
partnered with great companies
like Striim, and the other tool
that I'm going to show today
is a migVisor by NAYA Tech
which helps with that process
as well.
So with the partner ecosystem
and the in-house tooling
that we've built and
your own engineers,
the goal is to make that
migration as easy as possible.
We have some customer examples.
So one example is Evernote.
Evernote have moved over
five billion user notes
into GCP in two months, a
little bit over two months.
Pantheon migrated
200,000 websites
which they host from on-prem
to MySQL, just moving the MySQL
instance from on-prem to
GCP, in a couple of weeks.
And then Optiva moved
from Oracle to Spanner,
saw about 10x increase
in database performance.
So doing those migrations
are actually useful.
And usually you
probably ask yourself,
why would I enter
that migration,
that painful migration project?
It might take me a long time,
it might take me a long effort.
Usually is it worth it.
Sometimes it's not as painful
as you think it's going to be.
Sometimes the existing tools
can actually make it easier,
and you can get it done in
two weeks or in a month.
And sometimes just the
performance impact,
the cost impact, is
so great that it's
just worth it again as well.
So with that, let's try and
focus a little bit on migration
into Cloud SQL and
how to lift and shift
your application, hopefully
with minimal downtime
and minimal effort.
In general, the
recommendation is of course,
whenever possible, try and
take the simple approach.
And the simple approach is
just a downtime migration.
So let's say I'm doing a like to
like, a homogeneous migration.
I have a MySQL instance on-prem.
I want to move it to the
same instance in the cloud.
Usually I would
tell my users, hey,
there is going to be a downtime.
That downtime, of course,
depends on the database size.
Stop writing to the
source database,
perform a dump,
like a MySQL dump
or whatever to move the
schema and the data itself,
and in the MySQL dump itself,
we can also move triggers.
We can move anything
that we need.
Spin up a new
instance in the cloud.
Load the data to the
Switch the DNS or the direction
to that server, and that's it,
we're done.
We would re-enable writes.
We re-enable all of the clients
throughout your database,
and that's very simple.
Unfortunately it's not always
possible to take downtime.
And that can be from
one of two reasons.
One reason can be the
database is just too big,
so the downtime
will be too long.
The other is that it's
business-critical application.
We won't be able
to take downtime.
One way, again, is to try
and make some optimizations
to reduce that downtime.
And actually we
have an [INAUDIBLE]..
These are some real life great
tips to reduce the downtime
when doing the migrations.
So one is when importing the
data, disable all foreign keys,
all secondary keys, because
that way the database will not
validate against them.
So there is no need to
actually do that validation,
because you already know you're
moving the entire data set.
And then when you
import data, also
import it and dump it
of course in the order
of the primary key.
That usually makes import-- that
can have very, very significant
impact on the import time.
In terms of what are we
choosing to import into,
we want to make
sure that if we can
have the available RAM
larger than the data set,
it means that the import
time will be much faster.
Using SD storage or
high IOPS also greatly
reduces downtime, increases
migration performance.
And then during
the import process
itself, of course,
we are looking
at how fast the storage grows,
do we have any read operation,
do we have paging
that's happening,
and understand why import
is taking some time,
and also how to reduce it.
So these are all fine.
These are great and
great tips, but still not
good enough oftentimes.
Like, oftentimes, still, we
cannot take the downtime,
or the downtime will
still be too long.
And usually if we have a one
terabyte or several terabytes
MySQL instance, you just
cannot take the downtime,
or if you have a
business-critical application
that keeps writing, you
need to keep writing,
you cannot take
downtime as well.
I'll go back to what
we can do after import,
but that's why we have an option
of minimizing the downtime
when migrating.
So this is essentially
zero downtime,
and this is already available
for MySQL to MySQL migration.
In your GCP instance
you can just click.
I'm not sure if you've
ever seen this button that
says migrate data,
but this will actually
do the migration with very
low downtime or zero downtime.
And the way it's
done is it will--
we have our application.
It's still reading against
the existing database.
What that process is doing
is that process starts a new
instance, starts replication, so
like binlog replication running
between your source on-prem
and the database in the cloud
as if it was another
of the slaves of--
as if it was a database slave.
At some point, the data between
the source and the target
matches, and then
we can pause writes,
and then we can really have
minimal downtime, maybe
for a minute or
for a few minutes,
pause writes to the
existing instance,
move it to the new
instance, and then resume.
And because we had
replication running,
the data will be
exactly the same.
So we can actually move
with minimal downtime.
And from our
experience, what we've
seen with that minimal downtime
migration are sometimes
the make or break of
will I ever migrate
my application to the cloud,
will I ever migrate my database
to the cloud.
So for the MySQL
to MySQL use case,
that option is
already available.
We'll go in and we'll
show it real quick.
So let's say I
have a data source.
I'm pointing myself to the IP
address, username, password
of the source database.
I'm choosing the instance type
of what I'm going to migrate.
And again, best to choose
according to the tape
that we've shown earlier.
And I'm pointing
it to a dump file.
So let's say I ran MySQL dump
at some point in the near past
and I put it in a GCS.
I'm pointing it to a dump file.
I'm creating a replica.
And after a few minutes,
that replica will be created
and will have its own IP.
And once the replica
is created, we
can actually start
our application.
All you need to do in
your source database
is give permission.
Once you've given
permission to the database
to connect to a
slave, you'll see
the replica starts creating.
So in that case it's a read
replica that's being created,
and you can start monitoring
the CPU, the utilization,
the storage, and
you can actually
see this is a fast forward.
It was a very big database, took
about 30 minutes to migrate.
This is a fast forward
for two minutes,
but you see the
storage climbing up,
and then the latency
is being measured.
The latency
essentially tells you
what's the difference
between my current replica
and the original server in
terms of how far am I behind.
So at the beginning you'll see
it growing, growing, growing,
growing.
And at that point
it was 30 minutes.
At some point that
replication is done,
and we are catching
up on the binlog,
catching up on the binlog.
Once we've read all of the
binlogs from the source,
we would actually see the
latency going down to zero.
At that point, you can click--
you know what, what you've
seen there was promote replica.
Once we promote replica, we stop
write to the source database.
We're not writing anymore.
We click Promote Replica.
As you've seen, that process
takes about 30 seconds,
which means it's no
longer replicating.
It's now the primary server.
And once it's a primary
server and it is promoted,
we can actually start the
writes from the application
directly to that replica.
And that's it.
We're done.
We had a minimal
downtime migration
between MySQL and MySQL.
If we can go back to the deck--
Great.
So after the import itself--
I'm backing up a
little bit here--
essentially, once we import
it, once our application starts
writing, we start to tune it.
We are monitoring
the performance.
We see do we have
too many writes,
do we have too many reads.
Once the application's actually
running, we can [INAUDIBLE]
to improve the performance.
We can maybe change the instance
type if we need more CPU
or if we need more memory.
We can turn on
binary logging if you
want to create our own replica.
We're, again, having MySQL
instances in the cloud,
we can have a
replica, we can have
a read replica, can turn on
binary logging on our Cloud SQL
instance.
And essentially
we're ready to go.
We have our application running
against database in the cloud.
At this point we can keep
running our application VMs
on-prem.
We can take the application VMs
and migrate them into the cloud
as well to have the entire
application in the cloud.
So this was for a homogeneous
MySQL to MySQL migration.
That's great.
What happens if we want to
do a more complex migration?
Let's say we want to
migrate Oracle to Postgres.
So we have a big
Oracle instance on-prem
and we want to modernize
our application.
We want to move to
Postgres in the cloud.
So here, actually,
assessment is very important.
And this tool is tool by
NAYA Tech called migVisor,
and it provides you
with information.
How difficult will it be to
migrate your Oracle instance
into Postgres?
So you will choose a source,
you would choose a target.
In that case I've chosen
Oracle to Postgres,
and I have here five
or six databases.
What's nice about
this tool, all it does
is it will query
the Oracle metadata.
It will just run a bunch of--
a couple of thousand queries
on the Oracle metadata,
understand the current
usage, understand
are you using very
specific Oracle synonyms,
for example, that doesn't
exist on Cloud SQL.
What do we need to do about it?
Are you using
PL/SQL extensively,
and then you would need
to convert that PL/SQL.
Eventually one of
your databases we'll
get a grade, a
score, of how complex
will it be to migrate that
database, which is that bar
chart that you can see here.
So the ones with
the higher score
are more complex migrations.
The ones with the
lower score should just
migrate very easily,
because you're not
using any specific or
proprietary Oracle stuff.
And you can actually
even see why.
So I guess resolution
here is not good enough,
but you can actually
dive deeper and say,
hey, this is very complex.
Why is it so complex?
And then you will see
these are the features,
the specific features, that
are being used by the--
which are not
compatible with Postgres
or will need some
manual intervention
in order to move to Postgres.
And you can even see which
users are using this feature.
So you can say, hey, my CRM
app, maybe I'm going to keep it
in Oracle for now because it's
using some very custom stuff
that I cannot move.
But my billing app I might
be able to move to Postgres.
And then the last
thing that it will
do, it will also analyze
if the Oracle usage is more
of analytics or OLAP
usage type, or is
it OLTP transactional type.
And if it's
analytics usage type,
you might be better
served with migrating
that specific application
or that specific usage
into BigQuery and
not into Postgres.
So it will tell you, hey,
this type of application
is using mostly OLAP queries.
Consider not moving to
Postgres, but moving
to a data warehouse
that's designed
for analytics like BigQuery.
And those applications are
doing mostly OLTP, or mostly
transactional load, and then
it's better to go to Postgres.
So currently NAYA
Tech and migVisor
supports the assessment
of migrations from Oracle
to Cloud SQL, Postgres and
MySQL, and coming soon by them
is also migrations into Spanner.
And with that, I want to
call on Codin and Alok
to show us a demo of the
actual migration with Striim.
So we've finished
the assessment.
We decided that we want
to do the migration.
We want to move over
our Oracle to Postgres.
One way of doing
it is to Striim.
ALOK PAREEK: Thank you, Yair.
Welcome, everybody.
My name is Alok,
and I'm from Striim.
I sort of feel like
the brain surgeon
after the complexity
has been 100.
So I get into the
picture and tell you
how to do the heterogeneous
migration from Oracle
to Postgres.
That's my demo today.
What I'm going to do is--
click to the next--
OK.
Just want to make sure my
clicker is working here.
Let's go to the
next slide, Codin.
Sorry.
All right, just a little bit
before I get into the demo.
So Striim is a next
generation platform,
and we focus on three
different solution categories.
The categories are cloud
adoption, hybrid cloud data
integration, and in-memory
stream processing.
Of course, the focus today
is on cloud adoption,
and I'm delighted to announce
a partnership with Google
on cloud adoption, especially in
the area of database migration.
So what I'm going to focus
today is on the Oracle
to Cloud SQL Postgres migration,
and especially as Yair pointed
out, that downtime
is a big problem,
especially for
mission-critical applications.
So you might have a number
of different applications
from your CRM,
billing, payments,
core banking, et cetera.
And these might
not necessarily be
able to take any
kind of an outage,
but you still want
to actually move
onto your initiatives
for cloud modernization,
or for continuous operations.
You might also have
data on other clouds,
and you wanted to synchronize
that with newer applications
that you're deploying
on the Google Cloud.
So those are all the
benefits that you gain.
Of course, the critical problem
here is the downtime part.
So let's get into
the demo, and I'm
going to actually show you
how Striim helps you do that.
I'm going to just have
Codin help me with the demo.
And this is the landing
page of the Striim product.
There are three parts here.
There's a dashboard space.
There's the apps.
Apps are the pipeline.
So you'll hear me
interchangeably
use apps and data pipelines.
And then there's also--
you can actually preview your
sources before you get started.
So we're going to jump into
the apps part of the demo.
What you see here are prebuilt
pipelines, and remember,
this is a zero downtime type
of scenario I'm talking about.
This has two critical phases.
There's phase one,
which is instantiation.
That's where you make a one-time
copy of all of the data, which
could be gigabytes,
perhaps terabytes,
or it could be lesser,
and then followed
by a catch up or
synchronization phase, which
we achieve through
some very specialized
readers that help you catch
up the source and the target.
And ultimately, the two sides
are going to be in sync.
So let's step into the
initialization phase.
So this is a simple
pipeline that
shows a pipeline going from
an on-premise Oracle database
into a Cloud SQL
Postgres database.
The way this was built
was using a flow designer,
by choosing a number of
out of the box components
where you configure your
sources, for example,
and your targets.
And you can also transform
the data along the way,
because it may be interesting,
because the data formats might
be different, or you may want
to re-align some of the data
as you're going through.
Let's step into
the configuration
of just the Oracle database.
So here's where
you configure all
of the different
properties, and it's
pretty flexible in terms of
how you want to move the data.
On the cloud side, here's
where you provide your service
account, your connections into
the Postgres SQL database.
In this case, we are going
to be actually moving
two separate tables for
the purposes of the demo.
We're going to attempt
to do a live migration
of a million records of
the line items table,
as well as do some DML
activity in phase two
with a change in the capture
for the orders table.
So let's go ahead and
deploy the application.
And Striim can run in
the cloud or on-prem.
It's up to you.
It's pretty flexible.
And as we deploy it, you can
see that there's actually--
there's a deliberate
mismatch that we introduced.
You heard Yair talk about
some of the assessment
checks and so forth.
So it's important,
before you actually
do the migration, that the
sources and the target,
schemas, et cetera, sort of
add up, they're compatible,
there's no
exceptions, et cetera.
So here it did detect that
there's one incompatible data
type.
So we'll go ahead and just
skip this specific one.
We have a-- Codin has actually
fixed this in another flow.
So we're going to jump into
that initial load flow.
So let's go ahead
and deploy that.
And once we deploy it
it's ready to get started.
We want to check, Codin, whether
the tables are already empty.
So in this case in
the line item table,
you can see that
the count is zero.
And now we're going to go
ahead and run the application.
That's the one that actually
goes to your critical database,
which is Oracle on-prem.
Go ahead and you
can run that, Codin.
Start the application.
We'll also preview the
data along the way.
You can see now the data
is beginning to flow in.
In this case you have a million
records in the line items
table, and that
sort of keeps going,
and you can also monitor
the application progress.
You can see that so far,
we have 400,000 imports.
The output and input
obviously are changing.
So this is where a lot of
the magic is happening.
So things like
batch optimization,
things like parallelism,
things like event guarantees,
things like commit
semantics, all of this stuff
is taking place
behind the scenes.
So it will be transactionally
consistent when you actually
complete the migration.
So now I think we're done.
Why don't we take a
look at the Postgres SQL
database, make sure that--
and there you go.
So your million records table
was just moved pretty quickly.
And so the performance
is very impressive.
With that, what
I want to do is--
remember, this could be
gigabytes or terabytes of data.
What we want to do
is during this time,
all of the data that is actually
changing in the database--
so this is your
actual activity-- that
is being moved using a technique
called change data capture.
So Striim allows you to actually
have a specialized reader,
and in this case
let's step into that.
So here's where the
reader properties are.
In the interest of time,
we can go a little faster.
Same configuration for
the target obviously.
And in this case,
now, what we do
is we take activity from
the redo log of the Oracle
database, and we are going
to effectively replay that
on the target side
to catch them up,
thereby avoiding
any kind of outage
to the production database.
So again, in this case,
we have a mismatch.
Here it's more of a
precision mismatch.
In this case I'll ignore
it, because I already
know that all my data values
adhere to the target site's
schema.
So go ahead and
ignore that, and we
want to actually go ahead
and move the table here.
Again, the preview
option is selected,
and let's go ahead and start it.
Codin's going to generate
some DML activity using
a separate simulator.
This is where you're going
to see some inserts, updates,
and deletes.
And you can see
that he's running
a number of DML operations
against the orders table.
And then Striim,
you can actually
already see that now not only
are we capturing the data,
but also the metadata.
So these are things from
the Oracle database,
like the transaction
ID, the system
commit number, all
of the metadata,
the table in, the operation
type, insert, update, delete,
you can filter on
stuff like this.
And then you can
actually finally
log into the orders
table and see
that there is, in fact,
data present in this table.
This was empty beforehand.
So this is sort of a combined
technique of instantiation
followed by change data capture
and application that allows you
to, at your own leisure,
move your on-prem database
into the cloud database.
You can actually go
ahead and test both sides
while the migration is ongoing.
It may take you a day, a
week, or potentially months,
depending on the
size of the database,
but the key benefits are
that there is no outage
and you can keep your
operations continuous for your
mission-critical applications.
[MUSIC PLAYING]